So how do we implement the least
recently used policy that
works really well?
And it works really because
it exploits well locality.
The most recently used thing is likely
to be used very soon afterwards.
The thing that we haven't used for
a while means that there is less
reason for locality to kind of
cause it to be accessed again.
Let's say we have a four way
set associative cache and
let's just track what's
happening in this one set.
So there is four blocks in it.
For each of these blocks we
keep the tag and the valid bit.
And in order to track which
block was accessed when,
we are going to also have
an LRU counter for each block.
These counters take values that
correspond to the size of the set.
In this case, 0 through 3 because
there are four things in the set.
So let's initialize them to 0,
1, 2, and 3.
They have to all be
different all the time, and
we will see how that is maintained.
So, we start like this.
When we want to replace something,
we will replace the block whose count it
is currently 0 because that's going to
be the least recently used block.
So, let's say we access some block, A.
And we need to put it somewhere.
We will choose the place with
the 0 counter and put it there.
Now that the block is placed there,
the processor accessing it
and suddenly this becomes
the most recently used block.
So, it's counter now needs to be 3.
In order to make sure that all of
the counters still have different values
that means that all of the other
counters now need to be decremented.
So, the one that was 1 becomes 0.
2 becomes 1, and 3 becomes 2.
And now,
let's say that we access sum block B.
We put it here,
because the counter is 0, now, here.
When B is accessed after putting
it here, that counter becomes 3.
This one becomes 2.
This one becomes 0 and
this one becomes 1.
We will now put in block C here.
That becomes 3.
This becomes 2.
This becomes 1.
This becomes 0.
D, 3, 2, 1, 0.
Now we're back to this situation.
So I'm going to clean up here.
And now, if we access E,
we're going to find what was
the least recently used block.
And A, at this point, is because it's
been accessed the least recently.
So A will be replaced by E.
And the LRU counter here becomes 3
which brings these one notch lower.
So this is the state we have.
Now let's say that B, which is the least
recently used block now, is re-accessed.
What happens then is this
counter needs to become 3.
All of the other ones now
need to be changed lower.
What happens if the most recently block,
let's say, B is accessed again?
Then this count just stays at 3 because
that indicates that this is already
the most recently accessed block.
What happens if block D,
which is neither the most nor
the least recent, is accessed?
Well this counter needs to become 3 and
now we have an interesting situation.
We don't just lower all
the other counters a notch down.
We take the ones that were above
the original value of this counter.
So we take the counter that is above 1,
and
those are the ones
that get a notch down.
But the ones that are below
one stay the same.
That ensures that the counters
still have different values.
let's do another one of those
where let's say block B,
that is almost the most recently
used block, is accessed.
In that case this counter
needs to become 3.
All counters that were above its
original value of 2 need to be
decremented.
So, this becomes 2, but these two stay
the same because they're below 2.
So again, we have this situation.
So now you know how to maintain
the LRU counters properly.
After every step you can verify that
the counters have different values.
If they don't, then you probably
made a mistake somewhere.
So as you can see maintaining
LRU is relatively complicated.
For an N-way set-associative cache,
we need N counters
whose size is LOG2(N).
In this case the size of the counters is
2 bit because they need to have a number
between 0 and 3 to tell us where are we
in the order of access in the set.
So it's a four way set
associative cache,
that means we need two bits
per counter and four counters.
So for highly associative cache it's
something like 32 way associated.
You would need to have 5 bit
counters and 32 of them per set.
So this was the cost.
It's pretty high.
Worse, there is an energy problem.
We need to modify up to N
counters on each access,
even cache hits that can
happen very frequently.
So the LRU approximations try
to keep fewer counters and
do fewer updates on cache hits.